it was one of the worst natural
disasters of ancient times
in the year 79 a.d mount vesuvius
erupted
burying the roman city of pompeii in 30
feet of ash and volcanic rock
excavations have been underway ever
since the 1700s
but almost 300 years later pompeii
is still giving up its secrets including
this incredible find revealed just this
week
it's an eatery the ancient equivalent of
a fast food restaurant
unearthed in a section of the city not
yet open to the public
known as thermapolium the latin word for
hot food counter these food shops
were quite common across the city but
this is the first time we've got to
study it with
all the tools that the 21st century
allows us to use the venue featured a
multi-sided food counter
complete with holes to store hot serving
pots and its facade
adorned with intriguing and colorful
frescoes including an illustration of
the shop itself
a trademark of sorts and what was served
may have been advertised in these vivid
images including
ducks and rooster while three quarters
of pompeii has already been excavated
there is still much to be discovered and
sometimes it's not the grand arenas and
marble temples that teach us the most
about the lives people led two millennia
ago
one of the things that we can learn from
this restaurant is that the ancient
roman world
was very much like our world today it is
an
urban world it's a world full of snack
shops
just like we have cafes on our corners
they had little snack shops in theirs
you could get hot food a drink a
conversation
and the understanding that 2000 years
later life would be something like it is
now
way back then what do you know
they ate and drank 2 000 years ago
cheers to that
why not